الى السودان حيث اعلن طرف النزاع
التزامهما بالهدنه المرتقبه بدءا من الغد
وفقا لاتفاق جده الجديد لوقف اطلاق النار
اما على الارض فقد دارت معارك عنيفه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع في
درمان
وسجلت غارات على مواقع مختلفه بالخرطوم
بينما خيم هدوء حذر في نيالا بعد معارك
دانيه اوقعت 18 قتيلا وذكر الجيش السوداني
انه قصف اهدافا لقوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق كافوري والحاج يوسف وشارع الستين
شرقي العاصمه الخرطوم وابي حسب مراسل
الجزيره فقد اطلقت قوه الدعم السريع
مضادات الطائرات في محاوله للتصدي لغارات
طائرات الجيش
نقل الاعلام العسكري التابع للجيش
السوداني مقاطع مصوره لما وصفه بسيطره
قواتهم امس الاحد على مناطق السوق العربي
ورميلا وابو حمامه وسط الخرطوم واشار ضباط
تحدثوا في المقاطع المصوره عن تمكنهم من
تمشيط مواقع كانت تسيطر عليها سابقا قوه
الدعم السريع في السوق العربي ومحيطه
الواقع جنوب القصر الرئاسي بالخرطوم